[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host christina
ellis ramsey personality best-selling
author is my co-host today as we answer
your questions about building wealth
doing work that you love and creating
creating amazing real
relationships the phone number is a free
call and some say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it the number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five
five two two five kyle starts us off
this hour in manchester new hampshire
hey kyle how are you
hey sir i'm doing great how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so my mom is 57 years old
she's
losing her job next month
she's been working at a company for 22
years
and i'm looking to have a discussion
with her about her plans for retirement
she so far has been unwilling to
share
her financial situation with me and
discuss her retirement plan
so far
she has she told me that she's been
she's gonna put it off it's too soon to
think about retirement
and uh i just would like to open up that
conversation with her and get her
sort of on track for that
okay
why do you think she's unwilling to talk
to you about it
i sat down with her and asked her
you know what her what her plan was i'm
her only son i'm also a little nervous
that
it's going to fall on me
but she told me that her parents never
talk to her about retirement or their
financial situation and that she doesn't
want to talk
about her financial situation with me
being her son
okay
and that's her only reasoning
she might be embarrassed
to talk about it as well i think that's
the real reason
it sucks and she doesn't want to own it
she's ashamed
yeah
i i think
i really feel like i could help her by
giving her tools
to do better with her financial
situation so that she could have a
stress stress-free retirement someday
it's almost like she doesn't anticipate
on retiring ever that she's just going
to work
until the end
yeah that's a hard conversation i know
that you know i'm the person that talks
to both my in-laws and my mom a lot
about money and i found that one of the
best ways is not to just tell to not
just say hey this is what i should do
but to bring them in so it sounds like
you're pretty um on top of your finances
and so i wonder if you could just even
you know kind of talk to her about what
you're doing so she doesn't feel that
that shame and that you know finger
pointing at her but it's more like hey
this is what i'm excited about right now
this is what i'm doing this is what i'm
stoked about do you want to come with me
to an event do you want to read a book
with me or watch a video and just see if
it can kind of be an enthusiastic thing
versus a shame-based thing exactly yeah
the best way you can enter something
like this and and
i learned this accidentally because i
went broke
and then i started telling people about
the story of going broke and then that
they gave me because i gave because i
did that
they didn't feel as stupid because i was
bigger stupid and right standing right
in front of them right
and so then i could call them stupid and
call them out but i was doing that from
a position of my negative story not i've
got it all together and you people are a
bunch of doofuses right it was more like
i've got a phd in dumb and i've done a
lot of stupid and that drops the shame
down
the gate down and allows me to walk into
people's lives i didn't even know i was
doing it i figured it out 10 years after
i first started doing it probably before
i realized what was happening was that
god had given me the story of going
broke this wonderful story
and
it's wonderful to hear but not wonderful
to live
and um you know and basically i'm
running around the country for 30 years
telling people how dumb i was with money
hey i got an idea how to help you with
your money and seems it seems oxymoronic
but it what it did is it took the shame
barrier down now how's that translate to
you just exactly like christina said
it's you probably ought to say you know
mom i was scared about this for a long
time
because i didn't know anything about it
and i hadn't done a very good job and i
felt really bad
i felt ashamed
and here's you know here's what i
started doing i started doing this
and then i felt a little better and then
i started doing that and i felt a little
better
and uh if you've if you've not done a
good job with retirement mom that just
makes you like a normal person
and so i there's no shame in it i i
messed it up and i'm trying to figure it
out and if you want to learn some of the
stuff i've learned it would be my honor
to walk alongside and to teach and to
help you with that but
i'm not here to look down on my nose at
you and saying you've done a horrible
job i'm just here to say i did a
horrible job too
because i didn't know what i was doing
either
and i had to figure it out and that's
approach it from
bottom up rather than top down
and it's what most the financial people
mess up on they drop their glasses down
the end of their nose and wag their
finger at somebody
and talking down to them instead of
going hey man i've screwed up so i know
what stupid looks like
and so then you got permission to call
out stupid once you've done that but
you've got to establish that because
she's
um
she's probably a pretty proud woman it
sounds like and um
yeah the shame that she's feeling is
what is holding her off it's not that
her dad didn't talk about money it says
she doesn't have any money
and she is going to be working up to 70
years old probably because she's
probably broke
and so if you can help her with that
then you'll get her on the way
um let me send you a copy of baby steps
millionaires
and you can give her how ordinary people
build extraordinary wealth how you can
too you can give it to her and just say
hey i read this book and this was all
stuff i didn't know
and it blew my mind and because i felt
so dumb and just keep talking about how
dumb you are
that's a real good idea just to get the
conversation started and because it just
drops the shame barrier down yeah and i
think it's so important to just make
sure you tell her that there's no dumb
questions there are no questions that
are too silly i think even as many
people we're constantly asking questions
and there's constantly things that i
don't know that i'm learning and i think
some of the wisest people are willing to
admit you know
they don't know things so it's like no
matter where you are in your financial
journey whether you're brand new you
don't know anything about retirement or
you're you know you've read every ramsey
book there is be willing to ask
questions and be okay if you sound a
little bit silly in the process yeah but
she's not there right now she just all
bottled up with shame she just stopped
up
and so to kind of get the top off of it
get get flow going a little bit and
is just just start talking about how
talk about you don't talk about her and
don't talk about anything except how
scared you were and how inept you were
and how ignorant you were and i had to
get to learning about this stuff and boy
i sure do feel better now that i've
learned about it still don't have it all
figured out but i know a lot i know
enough now that i'm not scared and i
don't feel dumb and man i felt so dumb
and i was so scared and you know those
and that those should be truthful
statements by the way i'm guessing they
are i doubt you uh
20 years old had it all together maybe
you did very few of those people call
here but not most of us didn't most of
us have stumbled around looking stupid
for a while yeah and they're hard
conversations to have but good for you
for being willing to go there with your
mom and support her and love her that
way
it's awesome the only other thing you
could do is get someone
that she considers a peer or she looks
up to
that would speak into her life and jog
this loose
and that might be an uncle that might be
a
grandparent that might be a pastor i
don't know someone who's in a position
of
credibility that you don't have
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
done
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today she's number one
best-selling author we're going to talk
to you about your life your money your
relationships your career the building
wealth live tour is officially in full
swing we were in las vegas last week and
it was an absolute blowout we had over 3
000 folks there it was a lot of fun you
guys in vegas were
so fun thank you all for coming out
absolutely incredible we're going to be
in orlando
next week
a week from this coming thursday
and we've got a few uh stops planned for
the fall plus we got news you've all
been waiting for we've added our last
stop in the fall
now phoenix arizona
september
the 13th
phoenix arizona september the 13th so
the schedule now sounds like orlando
may 19th that's next thursday then we'll
go into the fall
phoenix will be september the 13th
sacramento november the 1st minneapolis
november the 10th in san antonio
november the 15th now that's rachel cruz
george campbell dr john deloney ken
coleman and me we can't wait to see all
you guys again we had so much fun
signing books taking pictures hanging
out with all of you in there in las
vegas it was a lot of fun and we're
looking forward to being with you guys
in orlando next week there's a few
tickets left tickets are only 25
60
for a pack of four
so uh if you want you and your wife you
and your husband want to bring your
friends with you hey it's less than the
cost of a pizza right so there you go go
to
ramseysolutions.com
events and get your seats now orlando
week after
this week from this coming thursday now
phoenix september the 13th sacramento
november the 1st minneapolis november
the 10th san antonio november the 15th
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code ramsey to get
the best deal
today's question comes from tim in
pennsylvania i have a 16 year old son
that does nothing but play video games
he seems to think he will be a rich
youtuber
how do i motivate him
it's a big one i feel like this
generation i've heard a lot of kids
recently saying they want to be a
youtuber and i think it kind of falls
into two buckets like saying i want to
be an influencer
shoot me you failed as a parent
oh my gosh
but i will say there are people doing
youtube so yeah and there are people
doing influencing
not anything to be proud of though but
before you come down on him i would see
if there are some nuggets there that
could be a career so does he potentially
like videography does he like
engineering is there some type of design
work that could interest him so dig into
that and you know see
is there something in that space now if
you start pushing him to explore
different options and he's not
interested in that
then it might truly be a motivation
problem but i would first see if there
are any nuggets of some sort of career
path that might be in there that's not
just being an influencer or a youtuber
yeah there's something i mean you you
you know we're on youtube and we make a
lot of money on youtube so you can make
money on youtube i'm not saying that
um and i guess in a sense in a weird
kind of a way we're influencers except
we really do stuff and have actual
thoughts we're not just famous for being
famous
but the um
but
here's the thing tim the way i would
approach it is this
i would take him
somewhere away from your house
coffee at a minimum
camping would be better
and uh just say my job
as your dad
is to prepare you for adulthood
to turn you into a good adult
a good adult has a good understanding
that work
is where money comes from
so my job as your dad
is to teach you to work
i have failed and i'm sorry for that
because i've allowed you to sit in the
basement and play video games that's not
work
and so you're going to start learning to
work
the bad news is i messed up the worst
news is you're about to learn to work
you're going to start doing some things
where you learn how to work because i
don't want you being 38 years old living
in my basement
so you're gonna learn how to work i love
you too much to allow you to think
that playing video games is an actual
job
it's not
it's what you do for fun
it's a cool hobby
it's exhilarating
but it is not an actual job
and so i'm going to help you learn to
work
now part of that might be
the nice things that christina was
saying because i'm an old dinosaur dad
and she's a nice lady
so uh but the nice part of the part of
that is part of that is i think you may
be drawn to something like video work
you might be drawn to something that has
something to do with the gaming world or
the youtube world and i'm fine to help
you explore some of that let's uh let's
get a camera
and let's see if you can actually make
some money
doing this
and let's do let you know maybe make
some money that's not on youtube
and not have to do with a video game but
still has to do with those can those
same kinds of skills and discover some
of those skills help him discover some
of those skills
and you know scratch the itch that he's
got
if it is a
creative itch
if it is not a i want to sit on my butt
itch
because some because some of these
people do want to sit on their butt when
they're 16. most of us did by the way
some of us just had fathers that
wouldn't allow it and mothers that
wouldn't allow it
and so i mean your mother would jacked
you up if you come in saying that oh
yeah oh yeah my mom is a challenger and
she would have
nothing to do with that but yeah
i mean she she would have been more like
me than you oh
you were like
let's discover his gifts and i'm like
kick his butt you know but i mean
but both of them have the same
motivation both answers are how do we
help the child not what tim wants but
what he wants for his son i want my son
to become a man
right men
work
right and it's a loving challenge like
it is a challenge that is a challenge
like we're not going to tolerate sitting
around playing video games like that's
off the table the grown-ups i shouldn't
say man grown-ups work let's just call
it that okay and so yeah you find your
gifts the bible talks about train up a
child in the way he is old in in the way
he is molded or the old king james says
in the way he is bent
and the way is bent the way he's
designed
turning up a child in the weight so
that's what you're saying pull those
gifts out start using them but you know
sitting around saying i really have no
plans in life because i want to be a
youtuber this is not a plan young man
this is not a plan this is a good way to
end up broke
and so you've got to have um you got to
have something more than that but dig in
dig in dig in
and do take him out of the house this is
not a sitting in his bedroom or your
bedroom or the living room he's got to
be away from the house this is a mono
imano a man on man
discussion i am your dad i love you so
much i'm going to help you become a man
my son absolutely this question reminds
me a lot of when people talk to me about
their kids not wanting to go to college
some people get really negative about
that right away they think oh my gosh my
kids are going to fail they didn't go to
college and it's like that's not the
case they just may have interests that
don't lie within the realm of college so
maybe talk to them about a trade program
talk to them about a vocational program
like really lean into their interests
and see what they are but bottom line
we're not gonna sit at home and eat
cheese puffs all the time like you're
gonna do something well you know why
they call them starving artists
because they don't make much art
you know yeah and so if you but there
are plenty of artists that make a lot of
money right because they create a lot of
art
you know they know why they call them
starving songwriters because they don't
write a lot of songs
but i've got friends who are in
nashville who've written a thousand two
thousand songs and if i said their name
you would know their name
tada they saw a lot of songs but there's
a work ethic involved in the creative
process
you don't sit around and wait on roast
duck to fly in the window you go shoot
the duck
pluck the duck and cook the duck this is
where duck comes from you know it
doesn't just fly in the window already
roasted and so this is the lesson that's
missing in this question
right right i think that a lot of times
this question of how can i be a youtuber
it's because the kids are saying the
glamorous side of youtube they're saying
you know an influencer and that's cool
but it's like no
you got to be willing to do the work
man i'm telling you the people that make
it on i mean we've had a billion
downloads on this podcast the people
that make in the podcast world they work
we show up here every day three hours a
day doing this and we like it we have
fun doing it but
you know most people don't understand
that that's how that's where this comes
from
it's
what
malcolm gladwell calls and outliers 10
000 hours of practice
before you're successful and it may
involve doing a whole lot of stuff
that's not on youtube before you get
there this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free homeownership and churchill is
here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today nate and faith are with us
on the debt free stage
right here in the lobby of ramsey
solutions by the way if you ever want to
visit ramsey solutions we got a huge
lobby and visitor center and free
cookies and coffee and places to watch
us do the show we do it for three hours
every day
live from one to four central many of
you consume it at different times on
your local radio station or podcast or
youtube or whatever but that's when
we're here doing the show and
lots of people calling in live from all
over the nation and uh lots of folks
dropping by usually got 50 to 200 here
in the lobby hanging out and so just
come make it one of your stops when
you're in nashville nate and faith how
are you
good we're great thanks for having us
absolutely where do you all live
we live in west lafayette indiana oh fun
good for you okay
and uh how much debt have you paid off
a little over 47 000. all right how long
did this take you 23 months all right
and your range of income during that
time started around 90 and ended about
110. okay cool what do y'all do for a
living i work at a university
and uh i'm mostly at home okay some
photography but as she waves towards the
babies in the floor out there okay
perfect good good for you love it what
kind of debt was the 47 000 it was
mostly student loans there was a little
bit of credit card debt in there um but
primarily student loans okay how long
you all been married
we've married since 2011 11 years okay
all right so 11 years but something
happened two years ago
a pandemic for one thing uh and in the
middle of that you decide uh we're
getting out of debt tell us your story
we had actually decided to do the
program right before the pandemic broke
out so we started financial peace
university in january
of 2020
um obviously not knowing what to expect
but we
kind of found ourselves in this cycle of
using credit cards to
do monthly expenses and just sort of
playing catch-up all the time so when
the pandemic broke out and we we
couldn't meet in person with our groups
we just had to take ownership on our own
and build that support system in other
ways
so we took advantage of things like
student loan pausing to really get
aggressive
about paying that back and it worked out
and our vacations being cancelled yeah
that was also helpful that helped you
yeah we weren't allowed to do anything
it was awful yeah
so while everybody else is panicking
about the pandemic and the financial
markets you guys are already plugged in
you're already like
we got this i mean we did a little bit
of panicking at the beginning like
everybody yeah i think we all had a
little of that yeah so but you uh but
but you still leaned in and you said
okay vacation money with all without it
uh student loans are paused let's get it
let's while there's no interest let's
get it knocked out that's right yeah
good smart that's smart very smart what
was the hardest part
i think the hardest part was seeing the
end from the beginning
right as you're as you're chipping away
at those student loans and we're so
conditioned to think of student loans as
this
this thing that just lives with you
forever right so um
just getting in the mindset that this
has an end date and that we could be you
know we could get these things out of
our life that was the biggest challenge
yes and amen man with this pandemic
pause that's what i keep telling people
pay off your student loans now this is
an opportunity and you guys are just a
shining example of that yeah beautiful
beautiful so
23 months when you first started and you
wrote it all out how long did you think
it was going to take you
uh we had it closer to three years yeah
and then and it funny how it speeds up
yeah well you get sick of it so
like i'm i'm done yeah and i got all
that vacation money i got all this other
stuff thrown out i got all these refunds
coming i got everything coming i just
throw it all at it and boom there you go
yep yeah way to go how does it feel to
be free
feels great it feels great it's freed us
up to you know pursue other things
we're
going to be transitioning into a new job
for me and a new location oh wow and
we're able to do that without you know
this thing hanging over us yeah amen
this thing that's what we call student
loans this thing it's a big thing yeah
big thing yeah i like it who are your
biggest cheerleaders
um well
we spent well with the pandemic i felt
like we cheered each other on a lot
because we were by ourselves um
our parents taught us a lot of good
foundations for finances um
my cousin cassie went through your
program and got debt-free as a single
mom and she was
actually texting us this morning i love
it where'd you go kathy
cassie but yeah oh i'm sorry yeah okay
yeah good good for you guys what do you
tell people the secret to getting out of
debt is now that you've done it you're
actual experts i i don't think it's i
don't think there's a magic bullet i
think it's just an intentionality you
know for everybody
there's there's that thing in your life
that's preventing you from being
financially responsible maybe it's
eating out or maybe it's student loans
what was yours
i think it was vacation yeah we really
like to be on we're on a vacation now
there we go but now you can afford to
that's right
um so it's just being intentional making
a commitment and sticking to it
yeah okay that's a big deal big deal way
to go you guys so for all those people
who have student loan debt and are
waiting to pay it off will you tell them
how does it feel to have them done and
to be debt-free
it feels amazing and
i mean i know that you know there's
talks of maybe a certain amount of
student loan forgiveness
um i would say
this is your education that's your
degree um
you know take ownership
take advantage of this time um
because it feels amazing
amen it's worth it you're done you're
done forever and you don't have to worry
about some politician fixing your life
you fixed it very cool very cool and you
brought the kiddos to scream with you
let's get them into the shot what are
their names and ages we've got walter
five amelia three and madeline just
turned one oh perfect
very cool and made the trip to nashville
as a part of a vacation very good very
good well done you guys we're very proud
of you we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you how ordinary people
built extraordinary wealth uh you can
too that's the next chapter in your
story we want you to be that so very
cool good job good job good job all
right it's nate and faith walter amelia
and madeline all from lafayette
wow
47 000 paid off in 23 months making 90
to 110 count it down let's hear a debt
free screen
guys
three
two one
[Music]
[Applause]
way to go guys
great job
great job
oh man those kids have no idea what mom
and dad have done they have completely
set them up to win it's changing their
family tree absolutely fabulous done
fabulous done
mandy is with us in san francisco hi
mandy welcome to the ramsay show
hello dave christina thank you so much
for all you do i appreciate the
opportunity to pick your brain here
today thank you how can we help
so i had a hard year last year as many
of us did and it left me in about forty
three thousand well what is now forty
three thousand dollars of personal debt
i also have about a hundred and thirteen
thousand in school loans
just started you know learning picked up
your book and listening to your podcast
etc so i'm starting to snowball i got my
emergency fund a little bit higher than
the thousand
starting to snowball and starting to get
the hunger right like starting to get
the hunger to get out of that all the
way good i have a little over 100k in my
401k
i'm a good earner
and my question to you is should i cash
out oh well not cash out rather borrow
against myself
fee is only 50
and the interest i pay back to myself
3.5
so should i borrow against my 401k to
get out of debt
um
and and what is your income
175 annual plus i get bonus oh good okay
well you live in an expensive area but
other than that you have a wonderful
shovel
and a medium-sized hole
you know you got 100 you need 150 000
bucks and you make 175 i think you're
debt-free in two years
but you're not going to have much of a
life during that time because you're
getting out of debt you're on beans and
rice
rice and beans but 75 000 a year out of
175 is pretty doable would you agree
yeah yeah i think so that makes that
makes you done in two years
and so um you can't borrow your way out
of debt
and so we tell people not to borrow
unless there's just some kind of a
moving around of something in this case
never borrow on your 401k
because uh you're unplugging good mutual
funds that'll be making you 10 to 12 on
average
instead getting three and a half and
when you leave your company when you get
a better job get fired or die when you
leave your company
that loan is considered due on due in
full if you don't pay it within 60 days
you get penalized 10 plus your tax rate
the last thing you need when you leave
your company is that so nope nope no
shortcuts kiddo just dive in you can do
it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today susan's in gainesville
florida hi susan how are you
hi dave um
i'm i'm in a quandary
i've been following you for years um
two years from paying off my house
and um recently i've been told that
i may need to have a liver transplant
and
in doing the research
my my insurance will
pay for for a portion of it
up to my yearly deductible
um
or my yearly my yearly
out of pocket
and um
but then
there are
drugs after
after the liver
transplant that you end up taking for
the rest of your life at
300
a month
and um
i'm single
and
i'm 60 years old and i only have 150
in my 401k and
i don't know
what to do the
research is telling me
it's a lifetime commitment of like 500
000
um
you know i just i can't i can't even
imagine
how i'm gonna
how i'm gonna pay that off well there's
so there's so many things here to be
afraid of isn't there
yeah i mean when you just say liver
transplant i go whoa you know
and then when you say 500 000 i go whoa
double whoa yeah there's a lot going on
i i can imagine you're scared
what do you make a year
well i work from home uh i work for a
company out of state um as a technical
writer so
um
i think i paid uh
85 in taxes this year
good and the good news is that
you know
that doesn't require a lot of physical
exertion
and so after you're in recovery you'll
be able to resume work fairly quick
right
uh yeah they're telling me about three
to six months yeah that's pretty and i
and my company
provides the short-term
uh disability where i'll make um
two-thirds during
during
the time i'm out
um
for the years that i've been
my heart just goes out to you i'm so
sorry for what you're going through i
just i can hear the pain in your voice
christina yeah
um well it's keeping me up at night it's
i mean i i just
you know i
i've i've been a ramsey for a long time
i've even i've even um
facilitated at my church uh on two
different occasions and
i've never heard heard you talk about
this and so
here's the here's the here's the truth
of the situation
sometimes uh for me anyway i don't know
if this works for you
but sometimes once i understand i'm
doing something
period
then the fear starts to go away
because here's the deal medically this
is scary
but you're doing it
you don't have a choice
right
well
not if i want to live well there you go
that's what i mean we're doing it so
game on
right
uh scary scary but uh obligation yeah
scary but straight up you know dying is
not an option here we're gonna we're not
when we have other options on the table
and so game on you know let's do it uh
and it is scary but you're just
embracing the the the facts of the
situation and you're going all right i
really can't i'm not really going to
worry about this i've just got to do it
now as far as the 300 a month you make
eighty five thousand dollars a year
you're okay
it's not five hundred thousand and it's
not five hundred thousand dollars out of
your pocket
this is a five hundred thousand dollar
total bill the insurance is going to
cover the the vast majority of you're
going to cover your deductible and your
co-pays
and
some other stuff that insurance doesn't
cover that's associated with this but
let's say it's 50 000 bucks
plus 300 a month and
we get to keep susan around
i like the plan let's do it
but i i i've already
almost depleted my emergency fund and
our other option is die
no don't think so
well also i do love that you said that
you're doing a lot of research and
you're kind of exploring what's out
there i would encourage you to continue
leaning into that i don't know if you've
looked into any of the
prescription drug programs that kind of
reduce the cost like i know there's a
lot of coupon programs like goodrx and i
know there's some other ones out there
so i would definitely go through and see
if there's any option out there that
will reduce that cost and then i would
connect with some other survivors people
who have been through what you're going
through have seen those bills and been
overwhelmed and somehow got through it i
think they're going to have some of the
best wisdom and insights for you so
here's what's going to happen susan all
right
you're going to have a liver transplant
and you're going to have
a bill that's 300 a month
and five years from now you're going to
be making 85 or 100 000 a year you'll be
65 years old a survivor of a transplant
surgery you're gonna be paying three to
five hundred dollars a month in uh
prescription drugs and you will have
come out of pocket with 50k
and you'll be fine you'll be all right
150 still there you know you're going to
work your way through this you make
enough money to work your way through
this um you can continue to you'll be
able to start adding back to your
retirement again this is not going to
bankrupt you
it doesn't have to not my retirement for
now
i would just sit on it right now you
don't need to write any checks yet
nobody sent you a bill yet
yeah actually
i
i i as i said i have nearly depleted my
emergency okay then go ahead and stop
your retirement and let's pile up cash
your stop stop retirement let's pile up
cash as fast and as high as you can how
long are you going to be on this list
waiting on a liver do you think
well i've been told it could be anywhere
from
two weeks to two years yep okay
so game on let's pile up okay
i'm gonna
um
and i i'm looking at at some
things
um
some organizations that that uh help
financially
um
to apply well kind of like connected
standards with their schooling sure
um
yeah here's the thing
i think you're going to have the 50 000
in cash before you need it
because you're going to put 50 000 cash
real fast together because you stopped
your retirement you stopped everything
and you're piling up cash like crazy
because you're scared
if you weren't scared you wouldn't be
human and i'm not making light of your
situation you called me asking me for
hope and i'm telling you you're gonna be
okay
but it's not false it's not gonna be
easy it's gonna be you've got a hard two
three four years ahead of you uh and
then you're you're gonna be okay
financially you're gonna be okay
medically unless something goes wrong
that we haven't discussed on this call
and so i can
standing outside of your fear which you
should have that fear i would be scared
to crapless if it was me
okay i get it i'm with you okay but i'm
standing over here not in the middle of
it looking at your numbers in your life
listening to a lady who's already a
survivor you're already a scrappy woman
aren't you
yeah you've been scrapping a long time
there's just one more fight double up
your fist girl
okay you can do it
you can do it and and i'm not making
light of your situation and i'm not
making light of you having some fear i
hear the fear in your voice i hear the
the hopelessness in your voice but my
job is to speak life over you
and it's and it's based in facts not
based in
the hope i'm speaking over you and
christine and i are speaking over is
based in facts not based in
pollyanna positive thinking or something
i can tell you that a woman that makes
85 000 a year that stops her retirement
can pile up 50 grand pretty fast boom i
can tell you the woman makes 85 000 a
year five years from now is gonna be
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
boom i know that a woman making that
kind of money can pay 300 a month in
prescription and be okay boom i can see
the math is gonna be okay
but i'm not the one facing all of it so
it's not as scary for me
so my job is to say hey i love you
i'm afraid with you
but you're gonna be okay
you're gonna get there you call us back
if you need some help honey this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
number one best-selling author christina
ellis ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
building wealth doing work that you love
and creating real
amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
america we're glad you're here triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number tim is with us in uh saint
paul minnesota hi tim welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can i help
so um i'm debt free i've been debt-free
for almost two years i'm 22 years old i
have a full-time job
i still live with my parents so i really
don't pay anything
to them for rent or anything i just pay
for my car and my phone insurance
and
i'd like to get out of the house just
with the market kind of things
unreasonable to buy right now and rent
is
outrageously expensive so i guess i'm
just looking for some guidance on what i
should do
okay
how much do you earn
uh i make about 27 an hour
roughly about 50 000 a year i think is
what it comes out to
good for you what do you do
what's that what do you do
i'm a public service worker i work for a
city i'm in public works
okay cool
all right fun fun well my first thought
is you know having been 22 years old and
struggled to get out and figure out how
to make
ends meet when you first move out is
roommates
i mean you can
rent by itself if you're trying to get a
one bedroom apartment that's super
expensive but if you're willing to split
it with somebody else you can really
reduce cost
how do you feel about that would you be
willing to live with other people yeah
yeah and i definitely have you know i
have friends that are just not in the
same position just aren't ready to front
money to move out and so i guess i mean
that's an option that i have looked into
it just hasn't been one that's at the
top of my list
well you make a good income and i mean
you probably could actually afford an
apartment if that's what you really want
um but if you don't have friends that
you know
like in your immediate circle that need
roommates i mean i know for me
i often lived off campus in the summers
and i had times where i had to ask a
friend of a friend or just kind of
coordinate with other people and maybe
not live with all my best friends but i
got to live with people who were decent
enough and made ends meet for me yeah
and they paid the bill and so that's
helpful
um so uh tim the way i always look at
these things is
on the short term
there's no problem here
but this is a bad long-term plan
it's living in your parents house right
right exactly so at some point
we have to uh
we have to launch
now what does that look like and um
rather than just looking at what it
costs today is where do i want to be if
i'm 22 where do i want to be when i'm 30
what i want my life to look like and
what is the best route
to get me there
my personal experience as a dad
is that it will you will have things
develop in you
when you have to buy your own gallon of
milk
and you have to uh fold your own socks
and stuff
and i'm not saying you're lazy but i'm
just saying the when when it when
there's no milk unless you go to the
store and get it
when there's no electricity unless you
keep it on
something happens in your personal
development that is good for you
do i want you to go bankrupt because of
that no i don't but uh when my oldest
came home from college we told her she
could stay for a little while until she
could get situated get her get settled
into the new job and gather up some
roommates and so she stayed with us
about three months and honestly that kid
is an easy kid like you
she wasn't a bother she could have still
be there wouldn't bother us you know but
it wasn't good for her long term and so
we said you know about three months you
need to get you need to get out and i
watched her
personality shift a little when she
moved out
i watched her square her shoulders and
throw them back a little bit she walked
a little taller she had a little
different level of dignity and
um
you know easier to get a date when you
don't live with mom and all that kind of
stuff and so you know uh all these
things start to develop
uh and so i i'm gonna recommend as papa
dave
not financial dave that you go ahead and
start looking really aggressively about
getting out it has nothing to do with
math it has everything to do with your
emotional psychological
manhood development and i'm not
panicking about it i'm not calling you a
pansy i'm not any of that i'm just
saying you know it's long term by
christmas if i were in your shoes i
would be out on my own now
uh
that also i think now back to financial
dave i think what i would do is hey i'm
with christina on the roommate thing the
other thing i would do
is i'm going to shop around because i
think you're a sharp young guy and if
you could find a garage apartment over
the over the top of a garage out back at
some rich old lady's house
and she would just love having tim there
because tim makes her safer because tim
maybe mows the grass or cleans the
gutters i don't know
you might get the deal of the century on
that if you can find it now it's a bit
of a needle in a haystack but it's worth
looking around for and you know talking
to the pastor over at your church and
going hey where's the rich old lady with
the garage apartment i need to talk to
her you know our rich sweet older
elderly lady but whatever you want i
don't know but i mean she's gonna like
tim showing up don't you think oh yeah i
think that's a great in between too
cause they're still kind of that homey
comfort where it sounds like he's having
a little bit of a tough time you know
making that transition so it's like
that's a good
i've watched young married couples at 22
do that exact same thing and they get
that rental and it's not you know it's
not the top it's not got the
it's you know not not the resort
apartment complex with 17 pools and
bracketball courts and skylights and
jacuzzis right it's not got all that
stuff but who gives a crap you're just
you're getting started man you're 22.
and you know you're i so that's how i
would do it i i would start figuring out
a way to pull this off there's nothing
on fire you're not a bad person it's not
a rush i'm not saying your parents did
something wrong you did something wrong
but you called and asked and i'm not
going to sit around wait on rent to get
reasonable because it ain't going to
well that's a great question that's
great that he's calling and he has that
fire in him he's starting to feel that
maybe i don't want to be in the parents
house anymore
it's a good start
some people leave home because they get
thrown out
i mean it's like violent and toxic and
it's not good you know
and so the good news is that tim
actually has wonderful parents and a
wonderful relationship with them so he
doesn't have that pressure
he's not you know because sometimes we
get the call like i gotta get out of
here you know and so it's crazy over
here that kind of stuff and he didn't
have that thank goodness and my kids
didn't have a lot of that just me
but um
but but you know i mean so but but
roommates are kind of a standard part of
kicking out there sometimes yep
sometimes renting something that's not
fancy enough that your friends are
impressed with your rental
by the way that might be a sign if your
friends are impressed with your rental
maybe you got the wrong rental
just a good idea
because it is a rental
yeah that's just something to think
about too
if your mom thinks it's awesome
you might have the wrong one you know
yeah there you go something to think
about tim but again i i
admire you and i appreciate you calling
and i think you'll be a a wonderful
roommate or a wonderful help to the rich
old lady in the garage apartment out
back this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
here at ramsey we love to have fun and
one of the fun things we do is we give
away cash so you guessed it we're super
excited to tell our listeners we're
giving away five hundred dollars every
week in may and a grand prize of three
thousand dollars at the end of the month
in our ramsey cash giveaway think about
what you could do with three thousand
bucks hello paying off debt pay off your
kids tuition fund yeah just start that
side hustle add it to your investments
wow to enter the giveaway go to
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway you can enter every day for
more chances to win no purchase is
necessary but you must be 18 or older to
win as great as the ramsey cash giveaway
is we're not stopping there to help you
crush your financial personal and
professional goals we're putting our
number one best-selling books and tools
in the ramsey ten dollar sale that's 67
percent off there's something for
everyone in the sale we know 10 bucks
doesn't just get you much anymore but
during our 10 sale gets you a lot hey
inflation has not affected the 10 sale
it's still there
it has affected our profits because we
pay more for the stupid books but there
you go these books and tools will help
you make a plan and crush your goals you
get up to 67 off check out the ramsey
ten dollar sale almost all of our number
one best seller is on sale there at
ramseysolutions.com
pretty cool stuff anne's with us in
houston hi ann welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
well my husband and i were in our
mid-20s and expecting our first baby
this year
[Music]
thanks we have no debt outside our
mortgage and we're scheduled to pay that
off in about four years and it's our
dream that i can stay home with the kids
and i want to homeschool them and but
once our house is paid off we can we can
come to live on my husband's single
income but we have to wait to that point
and currently my paycheck goes fully to
principal on the mortgage and now my
question is would it be beneficial for
me to continue working for a period of
time after we pay off the mortgage just
to like bank that paycheck for save it
for extra rainy day a four-door car for
my husband i don't know but um i won't
do what's best for my family and it kind
of still seems hard to give up that
income and i'd love to hear your
thoughts
um
there's not a
wrong answer
to this it's what you want to do
uh you're adequately analyzing the
trade-off
the trade-off is i want to be at home
full-time with the babies
or i can go over here and make some
money
if you add an element to that and say
not only can i go make some money but i
really like my job i really like what i
do
then there's certainly nothing wrong
with you being a working mother
because it's what you want to do it's
part of who you are
um yes it doesn't mean you're a bad mom
it just means you're a working mom
um but you if you say hey
we're willing to uh
not have the income and you know i don't
have to have
in this season of my life uh
the career
psychological income the career jazz
uh i don't like it i'd rather just quit
and i don't want to be there and i want
to be home with the babes
then that's a cool thing too that's what
sharon chose to do
and uh
she went from full-time mom and all the
way into full-time grandmother so there
you go
uh
and christina sitting here with me is a
working professional lady and loves what
she does so and neither one is wrong
which which one feels right to you anne
uh
i i really want to homeschool our kids i
know that that wouldn't be for you know
probably until the kids be like five or
six closer to them so that one
feels the best yeah but you're gonna be
four years to get the house paid off you
said
that's yes that is true yeah so there
you are
that sounds similar timing to me
yeah i guess that does that does line up
but i mean it it's it's okay
if you want to and of course a middle
ground is to figure out
uh what do you do for a living
i work in hr okay figure out if there's
some hr functions you can do on a
contract basis
from home while the five-year-old's
napping
okay you know you might make you might
make half or three-quarters of what you
make now working 25 hours a week
and be no strain on motherhood you know
yeah that's true
that's good advice and good to hear your
opinion it seems like something kind of
scary to give up but
well here's the thing if you quit today
and it takes six years to pay off your
house
that's not a bad choice
okay
okay and i i will go ahead and warn you
this is your first one going back to
work
and the first one goes to daycare
oh that's a hard day
yes that's true that's true thank you
dave sure hey you're going to do great
you're going to be a great mom you're
going to be a great provider the two of
you are you but just go ahead and go
it's okay
to say uh no i'm not trading money for
time with my kid if i want time with my
kid i'll just drop the money leave it on
the table done mic drop i'm out
but if it's okay to say hey i enjoy this
and i enjoy hitting some of these
financial goals and we're gonna do some
version of this and you know
that that's that's good too yeah i mean
and i think it'd be a different
conversation if they were in baby step
two there was a lot of debt there were
some challenges we might you know talk a
little bit more about timelines and be a
little bit more strategic but it sounds
like you all can't afford it so it kind
of comes down to more
what's the priority what do y'all want
to do obviously you could pay off your
house a little bit quicker
in the direction you know if you keep
working or you could take a little bit
longer and be home with your kids i
think it's just in this situation it's
more about what feels right to you and
what your family feels peace with you
know one of the things that people um
[Music]
deal with this is it really doesn't
matter what you do you get a version of
mom guilt
true story i i i get a virgin bomb guilt
because i'm working i get a version of
mom guilt if i'm not working and not
bringing in the bacon you know and so
there's always there's some version of
that and somehow we guys gotta pass on
that one i got zero guilt
[Laughter]
i don't know it's just not fair but i i
i've just you know rachel's dealt with
it christy when she was here dealt with
it i'm sure you have some i mean there's
just because society just puts it on you
they want you to do
uh be everything and um when you just
choose to be one or the other society
doesn't know quite what to do with you
and so you kind of have to just go well
i really wasn't taking a poll yeah i
mean it's definitely challenging but for
my family you know we've decided my
husband is a stay-at-home dad and you
know that's definitely helped with some
of the mom guilt and it's helped me be
able to raise the kids that you know in
the way that we want to it's not the
perfect solution for everyone but for
our family that's the choices that we've
made of course we could reach our
financial goals quicker if we were both
working
but you know for us raising our kids and
being able to potentially homeschool one
day that's a priority to us so we've
made those choices and we've made those
sacrifices it's not right for everyone
but it's right for us well and his
public service allowed him to retire yep
after 17 years yeah so that's a
different part of the equation too so
that's pretty cool i mean you got a lot
of options out there you can go a lot of
different directions so fun stuff
all right good stuff open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five thank you for jumping in america
we're glad
you are here john in new jersey says
when is the best time to buy life
insurance if we're in debt now
if i did ten times my salary i need a
policy for eight hundred thousand
dollars good should i get that right
away yes
regardless of how much debt i'm in yes
because it doesn't cost that much john
800 000 you're probably in your 20s or
30s and it's just it's the cost of a
pizza uh that that premium is not gonna
make or break your financial thing get
on zanderinsurance.com and get term life
insurance 10 to 12 times your income
immediately
because some of the saddest stories i've
ever seen are people in their 20s or 30s
who left a spouse and a kid or two
behind and died it was awful situation
yeah that's painful yeah it's such peace
of mind it's a simple thing to do but
yet if it's ever needed what it can do
for your family is just absolutely
life-changing
now we've uh had you know folks in
financial peace university and financial
counseling or sometimes just listeners
to the show you know report back
and
you know scott 28 years old something
happens to him and his you know sits
sister's wife with you know five or six
hundred thousand dollars or here's it's
his wife with nothing and these are two
very different stories
all for the cost of a pizza so no it's
not a it's not really an option you have
health insurance period
period figure it out
you get car insurance period you figure
it out
you have life insurance and a will
period you figure it out
we work it in
work it through
hang on baby this is the ride it's
called the great adventure
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today mark and carla are with us
from montana and it says on my screen
you guys are debt free congratulations
thank you
well done how much you pay off
178 000
all right how long did this take
11 years okay that works and your range
of income during that time
i'm about 125 dollars 125 000 sorry
that's yeah you just got a considerable
raise there mark
i love it all right how long you all
been married
34 years okay cool what do you do for a
living
i'm a physical therapist and mark is a
high school teacher awesome we raised
four children there you go
so i'm guessing 11 years 178 000 you
paid off your house
we did just last uh just few months ago
talking to weird people
i love it
way to go you guys what's this house
worth
you know in this market probably
400 plus thousand dollars i imagine i
would imagine
congratulations guys
that's fun so what you're in your 50s
yeah yeah both 54. yeah i'm just on a
side note dave i want to thank you for
um you know your
foundation personal finance
curriculum i actually teach that i have
for the last 10 years and it's now a
required class at our high school oh
thank you and thank you to the high
school and thank you on behalf of all
those students way to go man i
appreciate that
we're really blessed
we've gotten that into 48 of the high
schools which means 52 still need to
teach it but uh you guys thank you so
much very very cool
way to go
all right what inspired this story 11
years ago
well i think you know we did the larry
burkett class you know when we first
were married and and uh found it very
difficult to maintain our discipline
levels on that but certainly introduced
to it and and you know you just when you
have four kids all within about nine
years and you know you got to start
playing for college and things that we
had to get our finances right and took a
little while to get going but once we
got consistent
[Music]
we got it done we weren't very good at
doing the rice and beans idea so we had
a little bit of fun along the way with
our four kids
so i'd say that's why it took us this
long so now that they're gone and out of
the house we kind of went crazy and
finished paying off our debt
love it
love it that is so awesome what would
you say is the key to getting out of
debt
i really having a plan you know we had
we had a picture on the back of our
bedroom wall you know with okay here's
our here's our overall debt and all
these areas and and use the debt
snowball to be perfectly honest you know
the babysit plan works
sometimes it takes a little longer than
others just because you've got to be
consistent disciplined at it but
having a plan it's always about having a
system and it really works and sticking
to the plan making those choices of not
always the fun choice but sometimes the
better choice in the long run to be
where we're at now because it is a huge
difference
what did your kids think about this
during this journey because i mean
obviously you teach foundations which is
incredible but a lot of parents they're
not having conversations about money
with their kids so what was that like
really true yeah actually i had my our
youngest two actually took the class
from me when they were still in high
school the other two i wasn't teaching
the class at that time
but it actually caused us to do some
different things with raising them as
well you know just in terms of having
you know give 10 save 10 spend 80 kind
of idea give them some envelopes and and
because we weren't doing things right
with our kids in that regard too so that
was really a valuable time with them
having taught the class and also
applying it ourselves you just can't
teach what you're not doing yourself
well now also just standing up in front
of that class with those teenagers out
there you're going hey paid for house
shut up
you know
this right here works boys and girls
this works boys and girls you're looking
at a high school teacher with paid for
house so just tell me tell me tell me it
can't be done
you know so it can be done yeah and uh
so uh how much is in your all's
retirement accounts
well that's the problem
we uh we we weren't very good at that
part of it because we were so busy
getting four kids through college
and uh and just getting out of debt
getting our house paid off so we um i'm
going to retire here in about four weeks
with a pension and i wish i had done a
lot of the things that you taught in
fact i tell my students that very often
i'm really good at teaching this class
because i've made every mistake humanly
possible and i wish i had done exactly
what i'm teaching you to do and what
dave tells you to do so um we got some
other plans and some entrepreneurship
ideas and and we're just gonna go get
uncomfortable and see what happens good
for you
very cool
so uh what kind of business are you
going to open
well i've got uh you know carter's still
got a little bit of pt work to do and
i've um you know i'm starting to to give
presentations to school districts
um honestly you know and how to you know
show teachers how to invest in their
personal development and personal
finances honestly um
just really got a passion for the
personal development part of things and
so i want to share that with with other
teachers and so they can share that with
their students and get them inspired
about their future as well because i
think there's a lot of kids with anxiety
and depression things like that you can
do very well with some cres that'll be
great man
very cool
i love it man way to go you guys
excellent excellent job well done how's
it feel to not have a payment in the
world
it's awesome it's awesome you know we
can finally start
um making different choices you know
feel like we have so much more ability
to live by our values to
donate both our time and our money where
we want to rather than just being stuck
paying off bills every day
yeah way to go you guys good work
all right we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that is the next
chapter in your story i want to hear
about you coming up going on and being
millionaires now you're on your way also
send you a copy of total money makeover
for you to give away and stir up a holy
ruckus with somebody so good stuff guys
well done well done
all right it's mark and carly in montana
178
000 paid off house and everything
in their 50s making or did that in 11
years
making 100 and a quarter count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're back free
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it
way to go you guys
jessica is in st louis hi jessica
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
today sure what's up
um so my husband and i recently had a
house fire in our mobile home about two
weeks ago
yeah
shaking up
dealing with insurance
we have two little girls a 15 month old
and a five month old so that's been fun
um
uh currently the in-laws
and then we're going to be moving to a
temporary apartment that insurance is
paying for on a month-to-month basis at
the moment good um we still have not
heard back about like how much they're
gonna
give for the damages it's a lot of smoke
damage and some fire damage in the
kitchen it'll take a while
yeah so
we're actually trying to decide because
our mobile home is paid off if we should
um actually
use whatever money insurance gives us
and just sell the mobile home and then
buy a house yes
okay
because we have about 16 grand in the
bank currently
um
and then
we have about 28 000 in school debt
still that we have to pay off
yeah i'm gonna buy a house as soon as
possible here's
the i mean as soon as it works out we're
not in a hurry everything's okay thank
goodness everybody's fine you got a
place to live insurance is coming
through and all that but the way i
answer that question so fast is not
what's happening today
but what makes you better off 10 years
from now
repairing or buying a mobile home or
buying a house
ding-ding buying a house
mobile homes go down in value
right yeah that's what i was telling my
husband but he's worried about the
monthly payment on a mortgage when we
don't have one currently so yeah well
that you may want to wait a little while
you may want to run a little while and
save up a good better down payment with
the payoff of the mobile home and the
contents
take your time in settling that
take your time and settling make lots of
lists of things they owe you for
they will want to rush and settle with
you don't get in too big a hurry
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at
825-5225
josh is with us in west palm beach hi
josh how are you
i'm well thanks dave how are you better
than i deserve how can i help
question about baby step order and thank
you for taking the call
my wife and i bought a foreclosure to
fix up and planned once we moved in to
sell our old home
we've had an increase in income and my
question is would it be unwise to keep
the old home rented out and focus on
paying everything down pretty quickly
i don't know that that's a baby step
question it's just a matter of how much
you want in baby step six
because the baby step six is gonna have
a rental and a home mortgage in it right
right
okay
and then how quickly can you clear both
as opposed to selling it
and uh comparing it out the other way so
the way i think about these things is
and seems to be a theme today is um
okay ten years from now which one am i
going to be glad i did
working to pay get both of these paid
off and ending up with a paid for rental
in the process
or am i going to actually end up
building more wealth by getting my home
paid off
almost instantaneously by the sale of
the other one and then using this great
new income to pound the house the
personal residence then with no payments
anywhere how fast can i build wealth
versus limping through these other two
and that's just that that's the way i
would analyze it does that make sense
it does let me give you the numbers here
and see if that helps okay if
if i
right if i pause steps four and five i
can have the condo in the house paid off
in three and a half years
if i don't pause steps four and five
it'll take me about five and a half
maybe six years to get everything paid
off
oh no i'm not pausing four and five
under any circumstances
okay the only thing that's up the only
the only option i've got
option one is sell the old house use the
equity to clear your personal residency
faster
right
and by getting rid of that payment and
the other
option two is keep them both and you got
a five and a half year plan
how old are you
40. okay
and and uh if you sold the other house
you would pay off your personal
residence in what one and a half to two
probably right
yes
though in that equity added being done
with the payment and all that other
right yeah
correct
here's the thing
and i have the i have this per same
personal thing and christine you know
this um i have the same personal
dichotomy that you have if i'm in your
shoes because i i i love being debt free
and i love rental real estate i do not
love rental real estate enough to go
borrow to buy it
correct because once you once i get you
that free brother you'll never go back
i believe you because it's fun you know
but but i always give people a thing
okay if you're sitting here
you know if you want to say instead of
one and a half to two i'm gonna go five
and a half to six while doing baby steps
four and five in either case
um
and i either end up in one half two of
the paid for house and a great income
what's your income
250. i started a business a year and a
half ago and it just has done well i
think there's probably a significant
upside but i'm i'm basing this on the
250 we have now
well i think you're in a really great
spot either way you go thankfully this
is an equation where it's both
directions are pretty awesome if it were
me though i would want to be debt-free
as soon as possible like dave said that
feeling of being completely debt-free
that's just
amazing so i personally would rather
have a paid for house and then start
saving up to invest in rentals than the
other way around but i mean i think
you're looking at two really good
options right here let me throw out a
thought
this just popped into my head
um
if you got rid of the rental
and your house is paid for
there's two things that are going to
happen
that you haven't thought about and i
just did in this conference late in the
conversation here i didn't think about
them up front number one
you can focus more on the business which
is you're absolutely killing it at
because you're not distracted with
rentals
right
number two
this is not quantifiable but it's 30
years of observation
when people have zero debt that own
their own business they make different
business decisions that lead towards
greater prosperity than if they've got
debt hanging over their head even though
this is not big debt it's really small
debt compared to your income it's a and
it's hanging in the background but when
there's no
dull
backache
you can just run faster
i mean you've not got a debilitating
back problem that needs surgery but
you've got a dull backache called two
mortgages right and when you get rid of
that the you you're gonna your freedom
your creative
freedom
to do your business your business is
gonna go even faster because of focus
and because of
you got rid of that so
i'm probably going to go ahead and be
debt free today if i'm you as soon as i
possibly can selling that house because
of those things i want i want you to
have total focus on the business because
you're killing it i don't even know what
the business is but you're doing great
and i i can see that going to 500 000
faster if you don't have a rental and
you have zero concern you just got a
little different swagger
when you got no payments
you know and so i could just look at
people in business situation and just go
no not doing that
what you're kidding no not doing that
because i don't have any payments you
know it just it's a weird thing but it
changes your negotiating posture it
changes your decision-making flow your
critical thinking on it's different and
it's not quantifiable but i think i
probably have made more money
because i was debt-free and i didn't
have that hanging over my head so i'm
going to recommend that but alexander
we're going to both admit christine and
i are both telling you neither one of
these are in the stupid column
you know you're it's okay to go either
direction
we're just discussing you know smart and
smarter you know you know but that's all
we're discussing here so it's a fine way
to go either way as long as you continue
to do four and five while you're doing
which whatever it is you do
so the four and five aren't they're not
going to give you a problem your income
is going to solve any problems they give
you because you're just killing it so
that's pretty cool
that's just pretty stinking cool well
done very very well done
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five janelle's in
oklahoma city hi janelle hi how are you
doing better than we deserve what's up
so my husband and i have a question we
built a house in 2019
and we got a little excited when we
built it and built a home and signed a
30-year mortgage we are debt-free
besides that we have a fully funded
retirement
and everything we're just trying to
decide now
if we should
downsize and get to a 15-year mortgage
how much is your payment
so with escrow and everything we're at
2400 a month what's your take on 100
190
no you should keep your house that you
love
and but we're at but you should pay it
off
as soon as you can
okay you make 190 thousand dollars a
year
i know but my thing is if i can
i'm at like a two point two five percent
interest rate too so i'm super lucky
gives a crap
okay so just stay where we're at though
right now i think we have about 4
30 on it
all right let's stop a second
okay you are the nerd and the cheapskate
at your house like i am
you are exactly right
and your husband is the visionary
dreamer who built this beautiful home
oh well i did partake in that part oh
i'm not saying you made it without i'm
not saying you made the decision without
you but um
but but i'm saying he probably gets
you have probably have more internal
conflict
about the price of the house the 30-year
mortgage and he's just like i like the
house
yes yes and i'm the one that i'm like
well we could sell it and we could go
buy a 200 000 home we could have paid
off and you could sell it and live in a
tent and invest it all in mutual funds
but it's not a good idea
that's what i would do
[Laughter]
one of the one of the things we have to
learn to do with money
is enjoy it
enjoy your home and get it paid off as
soon as you possibly can you make a lot
of money you should enjoy that house and
get it paid off as soon as you can even
that you're not in the stupid zone here
you're okay
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
real relationships it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five lancaster pennsylvania jake is with
us hey jake how are you
doing good dave
good how can we help
yeah let's just call on um i have a
couple questions uh me my wife started a
trash business um i'm 23 and she's 21.
but we are currently renting um we don't
have any debt in anything
we were just wondering we would like to
buy a house
down the road
but our business is growing also
and we're kind of stuck on a crossroads
whether we should
keep investing in the business and
renting or sell a business and move and
buy a house to where we want
you would move to a
different city a different location
different yeah yeah we were looking to
move into a different area eventually we
would like to buy our house
um well we have some family down in a
different state actually and we always
wanted to buy a house in that area
and we just we were renting we had this
side business and it kind of grew up a
little bit more than we thought it would
what is kind of at the point well we we
haul trash um
and we're out of a truck and a trailer
right now we kind of outgrew that so we
kind of need to
buy a trash truck now or we weren't sure
if we should you know keep with the
business or uh
you know move on to buy a house
somewhere
what would it look like to do that
business in the city where you want to
move
um i think we could do it there um we
don't
exactly know how the market is right
there in that certain area where we
would like to move at um we
know where the market what the market's
kind of like where we're at now but um
obviously we would like to get out of
the rental also
how many are just afraid yeah
there's no
there's no panic with any of this
uh yeah how many customers do you have
well we do 60 weekly customers and we're
getting we started six months ago and
we've been gaining more customers every
week so it's
it's been a progress how has it why is
it grown so fast
um
i'm not sure honestly we didn't do much
advertising or anything well apparently
your competitor sucks
dad i mean that there is some of that
going on too um maybe get lucky there
but i just i don't want to i don't know
if we should keep renting like if it
would be a good investment to keep
renting or a good investment to invest
in our business and grow the business
because we have we have like i said we
don't have any debt we have a little
over thirty thousand dollars saved up
yeah it feels like obviously it feels
oxymoronic to keep growing a business in
an area that you don't want to stay in
right that's kind of where we were
thinking but
what i would do is do some real analysis
as to why
your business exploded and then go spend
a week
in in the new area and investigate
competitors investigate put market
potential
and see if you can't replicate that
there i mean if you did this in six
months what could you do in six years in
a place you wanted to live
yeah i mean that's that's definitely
what we're thinking we just um
like we didn't know if if we go if we
move and buy a house and that's
obviously going to
put a hurting on our savings or rent
well you can move and rent and start the
business get the business going and then
buy a house nobody said you had to move
and buy a house
that's true okay
well we typically recommend that we
usually say rent for a year when you
move to a new city so you can kind of
get to know the area and feel things out
and see where you really want to live
what would your could you sell that 60
customer list to somebody
um we were talking about it we have a
couple of google actually interested in
it um
but what would they give you for it
we don't we didn't have any numbers yet
um
we didn't really talk much on that kind
of profit are you making a year
well off the trash business that's
what's definitely part time so we're
making about fifteen hundred dollars a
month on that okay so you're making
twenty thousand dollars a year profit
full-time job yeah making twenty
thousand dollars your profit if somebody
paid you
uh a hundred thousand dollars for that
that wouldn't be unusual
okay well no that's not true because
you've got to take labor out of it
but um and if you take the labor out of
it
if somebody paid you 30 or 40 000 bucks
you had 30 40 000 bucks in your pocket
already and then you roll down to the
new area you rent buy a couple trucks
and get started based on the market
research you do on the week vacation i'm
telling you to take
um
then you talk about buying a house two
years from now once you got that
business up and running you got 60 000
bucks in your pocket to go start you're
22 years old
you're a rock star man
i got you okay yeah i just like i said i
wasn't 100 like i thought it was kind of
not too smart to keep building a
business in an area that we don't we
don't want to plan our routes in
completely agree
completely agree but the the part that i
am changing is you don't have to buy a
house when you move and you need to go
check it out because you got a lot of
fear on whether you can do this business
because you don't know the you don't
know the landscape go learn the
landscape you may go down there and find
out the whole thing's locked up with a
company that's been there for 40 years
and the county does all the trash
collection and there's no market there's
zero potential you may find that in that
area and you go well i got to have
something else to do then
okay
that's why but the good news is you're
not afraid of hard work because what
you're doing is hard work
and uh and you know you guys have been
you've been stepping in fashion you've
been getting it because in six months
you did this that's pretty impressive
and again you're 22. it's not to put you
down that's to say it's impressive that
you did this at a young age and so you
can my point is you can do it again the
secret sauce to this is
not the trash business in this singular
location the secret sauce
jake is you
you're the secret sauce you're the one
that's got the answers you're the one
that's got the potential not the trucks
not the location none of that you are
the common denominator of this success
and that's what's movable that's
portable absolutely yep that's what i
was going to say you guys are so
impressive 21 and 23 year olds three
years old to build that business so
quickly is amazing and if that is
ultimately where you want to end up that
different city you guys are going to be
successful you know in something else if
it's not the trash business you guys
have such great work ethics great skills
that i'm not worried about y'all are
going to crush it it is a uh
an extremely lucrative business
and that's why a lot of major
corporations like waste management and
so forth have moved into that space
um there's a lot of details with it this
is uh
amazing extremely lucrative but a lot of
people don't want to do it which is part
of the opportunity that he's jumping on
right now a lot of people don't want to
do
the trades and get their hands dirty but
when you really look around that's why i
encourage students to don't just go for
a four-year degree if that's not what
you want to do because you can make a
ton of money picking up trash or doing
some other trade it's they're proof of
that yeah yeah i mean it's just
um
yeah
just just whatever you're gonna do as
long as it's legal and moral be good at
it
and obviously he is this is the ramsey
chef
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking to sell your house
right now that can be a little bit
overwhelming the market is crazy
homes are selling for way over asking
price and demand is higher than supply
it's a lot to try to navigate
but look you don't have to sell your
home alone and you shouldn't it's
important to have a real estate agent
who knows your local housing market
inside and out and who will walk with
you through the process you need an
endorsed local provider by your side our
elps are ramsey trusted which means
they're highly vetted top tier real
estate agents that my team and i trust
they're pros who are excited to serve
you help you sell your home at the right
right price point
it's a little nutty out there it's not
amateur hour and so you really need a
pro in your corner that knows what the
flip they're doing get a ramsey trusted
elp ramsey solutions dot com slash agent
to find one near you ramsey solutions
dot com
slash
agent
dale is with us dale is in mesa arizona
hi dale welcome to the ramsay show
hello dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
hey uh so i was having a discussion with
my wife and uh we're talking about
the
i guess the appreciation of our home and
i'm on babe we're on baby step three
right now
and
so i have assets that are
paid off but we have
you know
coverage that we used to have
let's say three years ago
on the vehicles and trailer and and and
home that's skyrocketed in value now
and to be able to replace those items i
was asking her you know i was talking to
her and she's saying you know just ask
dave and see what he says
i was thinking maybe should i increase
my coverage
to
meet the
what it would be to replace those i
those assets yes
you should do that one you should do
that once a year
every year okay yeah you should review
because your home your homeowners is
your homeowners has a stated amount
some policies have a
a cheat that allows you to go up uh five
or ten percent maybe even twenty percent
but that's all and so you could have a
three hundred thousand dollar policy on
a house you bought five years ago and
now it's selling for 450 and it burns
you are screwed
exactly yes that's what yeah i work in
the fire industry and um doing
investigations and i see it all the time
that people just don't have any
insurance because their house is paid
off well that's a dumber yeah
but yeah no this is this is just
everything here's the thing what
happened dale was in the old days
um like when i started this show you
know way back
uh
you if you bought a a homeowner's policy
or a car policy it just covered the car
regardless and so if it went up in value
it just covered it
uh and then state farm led the way after
hurricane katrina and a few other
there's another hurricane in florida
that started the whole thing
but they got they got
they got hammered
in other words they had like houses that
they had 200 000 worth of coverage and
it was a 600 000 house and they had to
put the 600 000 house back they got
hammered and so they quit covering
the the uh
replacement
value
instead they cover only what the policy
says but the old policies in back in the
day like when you were a kid were
replacement value regardless there you
almost can't get that anymore on houses
if you do it's super we have about
60 to 70 equity in our home now
and we're working to pay it off
the equity doesn't enter into this
equation you need a policy equal to the
value of the home and you should revisit
that each year because you're not going
to be covered and the same thing on cars
cars typically go down in value but
lately they've gone up in value so that
you might want to revisit that but you
need a good go to
ramseysolutions.com click on er yeah
click on elp for
pnc property and casualty insurance and
get a fresh quote
on your house they'll shop among a bunch
of different companies and get you the
best coverage for the price and um
but that's a change in the market in the
last 20 years
that now requires you to be vigilant
because your insurance company is not
yeah i think that's such a great
reminder for everyone listening i mean
we've all seen crazy property values
skyrocket so i think it's just important
for everybody to take a moment and go oh
let's let's check let's make sure we've
been in touch with our
insurance elp and make sure that we are
up to date and that everything is
completely covered and if you you know
are questioning that we also have a free
coverage checkup at ramseysolutions.com
where you can just check and make sure
all your entrance is in the right place
yeah make sure you got the right kinds
of insurance at this phase of your life
and everything that's exactly right
but i just think it's really really
important one thing when you use a when
you're buying car insurance you're
buying homeowners insurance for that
matter life insurance any of them
you should use an independent an agent
and that way they're shopping among a
several different companies and they are
actually technically working for you
because they get paid when they sell you
a policy so they're going to get you the
best deal among all these different
companies versus like state farm which
is a captive agent
and that means they sell one thing
stay farm and guess what they're gonna
tell you is the best price stay farm and
it's usually not and guess what they're
gonna tell you is the best service state
farm and it never is okay their claims
are ridiculous
their claims are horrendous to work with
so
uh you know nationwide captive agent so
it's kind of like
if there's a famous football player on
the commercial
probably not the best insurance
you know that's what i'm saying so i
mean you know we got well aaron rodgers
on one side peyton manning on the other
right
and uh so
this is what's going on in the insurance
world so so
the the uh
what you're looking for
is a an independent agent that will shop
and get you the best deal and also ask
that agent to put a tickle in the file
if they don't automatically do it and
review and update your policy every year
especially in these inflationary times
now you can just be left hanging it's
bad and when you do that you end up
getting a better price
that's good a lot better price
person using one of our elps ends up
saving on car and homeowners together an
average of about 700 bucks a year
just by changing out from one of those
expensive name brands so so to speak
yeah that's such a good clarification i
know when i was in my early 20s i
thought you know to find insurance i
just had to drive to the local insurance
agent i would think i went to state
farms yeah and just knocked on the door
and said hey can you help me and i spent
way more than i needed to you never
checked it you don't shop it and here's
the other thing you usually know
somebody in the insurance business it's
like the real estate business or
whatever it's like so there always just
seems to be somebody you know that's a
that's a state farm agent or whatever i
mean i've got like five or six people
that i know very well that are state
farm agents uh they're not real thriller
with me because i tell people not to do
business with them but um but you know
that's
they're just it's not the person i'm
talking about is the company and their
prices are ridiculous so yeah that kind
of stuff so just shop around
and you're right though a lot of people
just first thing there well it's kind of
like when we're buying insurance we kind
of hold our nose
yeah it's like it's not the most fun get
this over with
you know which which arm do you want the
shot in i don't care just get it over
with you know
right or left it doesn't matter i'm
gonna be sore tomorrow anyway that's how
you feel when you're buying insurance
right it's about to stick me here this
is just
you know just
yeah it's not the most exciting topic
but
like you said a lot of people have
friends that are insurance agents and i
know especially with insurance and real
estate it can feel like oh man i don't
want to turn my friend down like i'm
going to feel bad but this is an area
where don't feel bad like you've got to
do what's right for your family you got
to protect your assets in the way that's
necessary um and and don't just rely on
friends in that situation yeah i'm gonna
feel bad if i lose a thousand bucks a
year
because i paid too much and didn't have
my house properly covered i'm gonna feel
real bad then so and that can really
happen so yeah make sure you get the
right amount of policy uh and that you
update it once a year and then you're
shopping with an independent insurance
broker these are all real solid tips and
again we're not in the insurance
business but we've got a network of
people with the heart of a teacher that
are ramsey trusted they're going to do
exactly what we're sitting here saying
right now and they'll shop your
homeowners and your car insurance and
get you the best possible deal when you
go to zander insurance and you're buying
life insurance they're an independent
agent they're gonna that website's set
up to automatically shop among a
bazillion different life insurance
companies in your particular situation
they'll give you the quotes of four or
five different ones and you can look at
them you can tell what's going on i mean
you then you get to decide the power is
in the consumer's hands when you're
dealing with that and that is the best
way to do this stuff
christine ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we are so glad you're here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
john and julie are with us hey guys how
are you great we're doing great good to
have you guys where do you live fairfax
virginia oh my gosh well welcome to
nashville and how much debt have you
paid off
360 000
whoa how long did this take seven years
and seven months all right and your
range of income during that time uh we
started around 115 and we ended up over
300 um at the end the last year yeah
cool good job you guys well done wow
very cool what do you do for a living we
run a digital marketing agency i do kind
of web design i do graphic design okay
wow you're doing well congratulations
very good okay seven years and seven
months of 360. i'm guessing this might
be the house yes we did
look at that weird people
i love it i love it what's this house
worth uh about 6 50.
way to go you guys
i love it excellent excellent job so
tell us the story what happened seven
years and seven months ago to start this
process well it actually started a
little bit before that yeah we uh 2005
had been married a year we bought a
house that we couldn't afford on zero
down did it all the wrong way didn't
know about you did it all the wrong way
four years later uh we had this little
thing called a balloon payment oh we
didn't realize that we had and so they
said hey in a few months you're going to
owe 63 000 which we did not have
um and so we short sold our house and
kind of hit rock bottom then we were
driving this uh 85 oldsmobile that had
rust and everything we just had two kids
oh my god we had two small kids and so
that was around that time that someone
mentioned this guy dave ramsey and uh we
got the book the total money makeover
when you're at that level you just won't
listen to anything yeah yeah any advice
that anybody has that's uh better than
what we've been through and so we read
that in a few days and we're like okay
we need to do this and so we paid off
our student loans our credit cards all
those things and then we started kind of
on the 3b
plan of saving a down payment we saved
20 percent um bought a house seven years
seven months ago and then paid it off as
quick as we could we didn't want to do
it yeah
like that before yeah yeah we're not
going back there no no this was not fun
and i hope you got a better car now we
do we do we got rid of that one yeah
that was a serious hooptie i did
threaten my son who's about to drive
soon he said hey you know i could have
saved that one for you but he's glad
that i didn't
he considers that as an act of love yeah
getting rid of the hooptie yeah all
right good guys very cool man you did it
that's a long journey
11 years but it's all
done yeah yeah that's a lot of money 360
000
how did you do it what did you do to get
out of debt
well we stuck to a budget which was uh
really great to have
encouragement from our family and from
we also um
teach fpu
church and with some small groups and
they've been cheering us on and thank
you yeah
what was the hardest part
um
i think looking at it and seeing that it
was still a long ways off most of the
time you know it was like a lot of the
progress happened in the last couple
years um turns out during a pandemic
everybody needs a website so our
business kind of while other businesses
were struggling we we took off um
and so but i think the first few years
it was not seeing a lot of progress you
know just kind of paying a little bit
extra but just kind of knowing that we
had this goal
uh to try to pay it off by the time i
turned 40. we had charts on the walls we
had we listened to your show like 24 7
all the time he's on we work in the same
office
and he'll turn on your show and we'll
just keep listening to all the debt free
screams everybody's um
stories they are really inspiring to us
and so we were that was what kept us
going yeah and you get to see them in
real life when you teach in the class
yes oh yeah yeah it's amazing we usually
save it toward a little bit at the end
of this last class we hadn't told them
that we were debt free 100 until toured
we got later in the steps i think they
were all just blown away yeah well
congratulations yeah okay so how much is
in the retirement accounts
uh about 400 some so we've crossed the
line last year yes your baby steps
millionaires
how old are you guys
39 i just turned 40. oh 40 years old and
you're millionaires yeah and all the way
from a rust bucket
yeah i mean that's pretty cool yeah this
is proof it can be done you did it 11
years 0 to 60 in 11 years right yep yep
yeah and hippie rock bottom yeah
wow
i wanted to change our legacy for our
kids and for our family you guys are
cool
you guys are very cool i love these
numbers that's amazing so how does it
feel how's it feel to be debt free like
you're done house and everything
it's so wonderful we uh the grass does
feel different she's got she's got a
garden that she loves to to do stuff in
as well and um yeah it's just it's just
wonderful yeah live like no one else
t-shirts gazelle t-shirts i mean yeah
you guys still i still i'm still
pinching myself this is awesome this is
very cool well congratulations you guys
we're very proud of you thank you all
the way through that's exactly what
you're supposed to do
well we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you you should be in
there actually and how ordinary people
build extraordinary wealth how you can
too maybe you can even give it away and
we'll give you a copy of a total money
makeover to give away and i'm gonna do
something else for you to give away i'm
gonna give you a
one-year membership to ramsey plus which
sets somebody up for financial peace
university in every dollar of course and
you can give that away and you guys will
have great use for all of that because
teaching the class you'll see people
that you can scholarship in that way
yeah and so that'll be a great way for
you to help them out so very cool
financial piece for free for a year not
bad thank you good stuff all right guys
way to go let's get the kiddos in what
are their names and ages jeremiah 15 15
elias who is 14
and alicia who is 11 and sammy who is
10. all right
cool beans we're ready to go i love it
all right john and julie and the gang
from virginia
360 000 paid off house and everything on
the way to becoming baby steps
millionaires seven years seven months
making 115 to now 300. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream you guys
ready three two one
[Applause]
boom
that is how it is done
so
they are why
sometimes you hear me get
visibly angry when someone says
millionaires are just lucky
i get angry when i hear that there
wasn't any luck involved in that it was
hard work
and sacrifice
and they happened to catch a great
timing wave with their business
and took advantage of it and went zoom
zoom
if you're selling plexiglass in the last
two years you've had a pretty good run
you know and if you're building websites
you've had a pretty good run
um so there's the thing and on top of
that they had a plan they had a system
and they went from losing a home in a
short sale that's a foreclosure
pre-foreclosure deal
driving a rust bucket a 500 car
and now you're looking at four teenagers
whose lives have been completely changed
that's pretty amazing
that's incredible and i mean you could
even hear like there was overwhelm at
the beginning 360 000 that's a huge
mountain to climb so it's like
it's okay to feel overwhelmed but that
doesn't mean don't do it do it you guys
are proof that it can be done
but if you're listening at this moment
or you're listening back at a different
time to this particular broadcast
and you're at the bottom
you're driving a 500 car
and you lost your house
you're gonna be okay
it's gonna be all right
i went bankrupt and lost everything when
i was 28. i'm okay
i'm better than i deserve as a matter of
fact so
uh there's a lot of hope here folks i'm
just saying and when you see people like
that they just look like hope to me they
just are proof
that if you plant corn
corn will grow wow who knew
you know that's amazing it's the perfect
before and after y'all are absolutely
such amazing examples beautiful
beautiful beautiful
great recovery nice save
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture today psalms 1-1 blessed
is the one who does not walk in step
with the wicked
or stand in the way that sinners take or
sit in the company of mockers
winston churchill said an appeaser is
one who feeds the crocodile hoping it
will eat him last
[Laughter]
you know i haven't seen that um psalm
in a while
and
it kind of catches me here
blessed is the one who does not walk in
step with the wicked or stand in the way
that sinners take or
sit in the company of mockers
we have a lot of professional mockers on
social media now
it is they're called trolls
and uh you know when you
sit in the company of them
you are not blessed isn't that
interesting
i have not seen i i mean i i never
thought of um
mocking is
you know because i'm a sarcastic person
right but i never think of it as um as
serious as
in step with the wicked it's in the same
sentence
you know wow you're blessed if you're
not in step with a wicked if you're not
standing in the way that sinners take
which kind of makes sense i mean i get
that one right but sitting in the
company of mockers that's kind of comes
in from left field a little bit for me
interesting very cool stuff christina is
my co-host today and christina is also
on the phone in riverside california hi
christina how are you
good game how are you
good your phone sucks can you speak
directly into it
yeah can you hear me now yes ma'am much
better how can we help
all right so my husband and i we
actually saw you thursday in vegas so
thanks for that thank you um
yeah so we're in vegas that's 6
and we're about six years out on
retirement and we purchased land about
two years ago to kind of start the
project towards building um our
retirement home
and over the last two years um just the
market has kind of priced us out of um
doing like a custom home build
um we're considering uh alternate uh
methods like a modular manufactured home
along with custom built and was
wondering what your advice on that would
be
when you say modular
um it can mean a lot of things
all right
if it rolls up on wheels
and i'm done and when you're done with
it i can tell
as a consumer
when i walk up to it that it rolled up
on wheels
it's going to go down in value
i would not do that but there are plenty
of construction techniques now that
include
sections of a home pre-built and rolled
in and framed up around
and you have you know for instance
pre-done
uh
floor joists or pre-done rafters
that kind of thing or wall systems
sometimes are fine all of that's fine
that is technically under the heading of
modular
as well
but uh no i would not buy a trailer or a
glorified trailer it's going to go down
in value
okay
yeah i mean we're uh we're definitely
looking at the modular option as well
i'm just hoping to find something in our
price range we have about uh 220
thousand dollars in cash right now well
you also have a home in rivers side that
you're going to sell
when you retire well
we're actually hoping to keep it
okay well i mean
it depends on how you want to retire i
guess
yeah
i don't know i mean i might rather have
a rent where's the retirement home
uh in
puget sound washington
okay i might rather have a rental or two
in that area that i paid cash for that
the total of is less than
your current home in riverside rather
than having a rental in california
okay
and have a paid for nicer property that
i live in for my retirement years
um matter of fact i know i would rather
do that um because long-distance
landlording uh is less than fun for me i
don't i don't really have good results
with that usually so i try not to do it
um
not on residential for sure
um
so that's kind of the way i would go
the other thing i think christina to
keep in mind is um you don't have to
build that house this year
and
while i don't think the prices of homes
are going to come down substantially the
components to build a home are coming
down
and because they were
factories that were shut down during the
pandemic and so lumber
as the supply comes up we're seeing the
prices drop
uh steel went nuts for a while on
commercial buildings um i think we're
going to see that stabilizing come back
down and we're seeing some of the major
components
uh come back down um you know once the
oil thing straightens out and it's not
anywhere near it right now because biden
keeps screwing with it but if oil prices
come back down then you'll see stuff
like asphalt shingles which have oil in
them asphalt's made with with oil so you
know they'll see the the shingles on a
house come back down so some of this
stuff is driven by in inflationary
pressures that might not
that i don't think are going to be
sustained
and so if i were going to build a house
i might rather build a house two years
from now than i would today
because i might see prices cheaper on
the components of that something else to
consider
yeah and she mentioned that she was
working with a friend on kind of
dreaming up this retirement home and so
i would be curious just you know with
that friend what their role is in that
process i know obviously with friends it
can be hard to then want to shop around
but if that friend has skin in the game
you know that might be an extra price
factor so just keeping your options open
especially as prices start coming down
being willing to you know just look
around and be open to options
yeah you're talking about that as a
builder
yeah i look up to several different
builders
and how they put the package together
and the timing on it is everything it
really is i mean if you bought lumber
six months ago you paid a good deal more
than you pay for it today
that's that's what i'm talking about
that's the thing so
um and uh there's nowhere near the
shortage that there was six months ago
uh i mean there was jokes about you know
memes going around with like two befores
like bars of gold and stuff you know
and that that's all that pressure is
gone at this point so far all right
james is with us in mesa arizona hi
james how are you
hey dave first off big fan and i need
some words of wisdom from you we'll try
so this two-part question first part is
i'm thinking about doing a career change
i
just turned 32 and i did bankruptcy
about a year and a half ago
and
i currently am in the service industry
as a poll technician for a company out
of mesa and i'm looking to change
careers to become a lineman through one
of the electrical companies out here
and
the second part to the question and i
would like your opinion on that
how to approach that and then the second
part to that question is
like i said i filed bankruptcy 32 am i
still
young enough to start investing now and
because i eventually would like a family
who would like to get married and have
my own house at some point
but
i would like to get my career on track
first so if i could get your opinion and
some words of wisdom on that that'd be
great
the only thing i know about linemen is
the ones i've known personally that were
friends or relatives and the thing i
know about them is they make a lot of
money
they work really really hard
and at times it's more than a wee bit
dangerous
does that sound familiar
does that sound right yes yes is that
what you've heard
yes sir
i mean expand and some a lot of a lot of
the ones i know also there's some travel
involved a lot of times depending on
what type of work you're doing
i was a volunteer firefighter so the
danger part ain't no worry for me
well i mean it's it's just a matter of i
i'm not afraid i just want to be wise
and that's that's not you know i don't
want to be crazy about it i don't think
it's
uh if it was life-threatening
uh in the sense that people died every
day doing it then there would be a
different process used than that right
so it's not that but it's just you know
you want to be a high rise window washer
there's you know there's danger involved
and you get paid well you know that kind
of thing so yeah i think that's fine and
uh as long as you're working and you
start getting handling your money right
i don't know that you have to be some
kind of big-time investor before you get
married and have a family yeah well i
would encourage you to check out some of
ken's material on um you know just how
to pick the right career because maybe
it's being a lineman but i don't know
how much research you've done into other
options but just making sure that you're
picking the right thing
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
you